sometimes I wonder if initiating it was
the right thing to do what do you mean
am I not ready no you're ready zapper up
with that there is no doubt I worry
about you and care for your happiness
once you become a tech oh man so there's
Pistor it is the same as that in our
chapel accessible only to the combined
energies of to techno masters
you
utilize the entrance be on the main
movie when you must come for being so
old it's in great condition what exactly
answers inside the dome very
creatures are not belong here the very
presence is a danger to the relics we
must seek out the origin I remember well
the first time I came here was
fascinated I really thought I was part
of an elite I've become disillusioned
since then if all this knowledge indeed
gives us some sort of power they're
still faced with so many obstacles that
we can't do anything with mortal danger
this is the main room the console of
activated and heat it's worth
his registration which they take 2076
subject 12 the subject appears the
climate eyes pulse elevated but steady
unaffected by any visible health
concerns James IV feel great so alive
the hearts racing man if you want to
take on the world it's tiana students a
bit overwhelming subjects self-report is
consistent in substantially with our
measurements of human subjects or minus
Z DZ activity levels acutely higher than
any ever associated with a human not
subjected to mutation the only adverse
side effects it appears the new temple
in creeks and coral and cerebral
electricity dangerous levels that
necessitate the party convention the
device capable backward with such
surplus in order to afford subdivision
this man talking about techno man see
about mutations as if I can't believe
and yet it still might be so this
recording dates to the first settlers
speaks of the first Technomancer
shocking perhaps where did you think our
abilities came from a divine power
I don't but we have no physical signs of
mutation and I don't know any mutant
that has our gifts and why should any of
those things matter might not our
mutations simply be of a different form
this brings us to the most important
point what you have seen unifies us
unifies the techno manswers this secret
must be kept from all other humans if
this information was discovered by say
the ASC you would become nothing but
slaves our situation is already
incredibly undesirable we're not only
isolated but used as human bombs take a
walk by the mutant pen in the slums one
day that is what our lives could have
been don't be dismayed have been through
this as well so have all the other
Technomancer officers and abundance
knowledge of this revelation makes you
one of us now more so than your skills
but now it's time to deal with the
creatures infesting the dome it would be
a real shame of the installations who
are damaged we will no longer be able to
hold initiation trials here yes yes of
course master I haven't found an opening
yet so they must have reached lower in
the dome
then that's where we must go
I will divert the attention of these
creatures to the base of the dome
you
good
you